born and raised in Hong Kong Helen chant
looks at the recreation of a main symbol
of the territory's umbrella movement a
so-called Lenin wall this is the site of
the first that went up in 2014
five years on protesters are again
building them to post messages and
themes that have brought millions out to
the streets while Helen agrees with the
focus of what's happening now she did
not back then she believes freedoms are
being stripped away in the situation now
is more urgent to me I think it's only
just the youngsters matter and they that
striving for some of that believes I'm
already of more than fifty years old a
woman and I just asked for the peace and
normal life of Hong Kong to mark the
fifth anniversary of the umbrella
movement a rally was held next to Hong
Kong's seat of government hundreds of
thousands gathered in Tamar Park as with
most of the larger protest events there
was anger directed at police they've
been accused of using excessive force
against demonstrators a surveillance
helicopter hovering over the rally a
target of the protesters lazers
pro-democracy leaders say that the
success size and passion with this
protest compared to the umbrella
movement five years ago is rooted in how
its organized Isaac Cheng was only 14
when he was out on the streets during
the umbrella movement now he's one of
the leaders of a pro-democracy political
party born out of the umbrella movement
the differences of the previous movement
a day
prescience is the previous movement have
one thing called nice Asian who are
leading the whole campaign
he also says there are many people
driving the protests now in their
seventeenth weekend as the range of
issues is much larger than five years
ago bringing out people of all ages as
with many of the recent large protests
riot police are called in to clear out
the remaining protesters the steps of
the original Lenin wall now reclaimed by
police Scott hilar al Jazeera Hong Kong